boy it's like a gamble
[Music]
I brought here today because I wanted to
I know you love war the only way to
solve problems yeah this cartoon is
called take heed mr. Tojo it's already I
can understand exactly everything yeah
it's done by the guy who created Woody
Woodpecker and and written by the guy
who created Dennis the Menace alright
let's play and I'm pretty excited right
now
show show people the soap yeah you're
damn right the War Department and the
boy look ticking mr. Tojo see it's all
coming guys I'm nervous about me Walter
Lantz Bureau of Aeronautics yeah my dad
was in the Bureau of Aeronautics
he died in e-town active duty so this is
actually done business propagation was
actually done in 1943 but it's the
future okay so they're looking into the
future here no I think cartoons are a
great way to see where we'll go the
grounded nature of them really show you
he is the worst sleeper well we has what
we call sleep apnea now but they didn't
have that in 53 yeah but what's with the
whistle
well he needs the bane mask that's how
you get rid of it okay so his son
obviously is gonna kill gee not Dennis
the Menace he at all kids are fun also a
son as a pinup I'm not afraid of gun why
I shut down a zero without a gun
oh my god you got to take those back
part of the play it was back in 1943
when I was a boarder flattop in the
Pacific oh I'm going back back in time
back when I had a weird pig nose like
you
RadioShack then they call it the shack
back then no I'm sorry think I know
Oh Oh God very it's already the short
hand a little uncomfortable or war then
I know but in wartime deal so you could
use the really bad word but Oh God for a
minute I thought he was personal shoes
yeah well it looked like he was more in
the middle of his body
Oh No what what's wrong I think you had
some in his eyes I don't think that's
what you thought no do you think that
was racist oh my god Wow
that's neither going out to get him I'm
still getting over the other scene just
an empath so they're pretty impact share
together yeah that guy's dead okay like
what was the note from the network go
big not racist enough yeah more racist
becomes obviously as a tithi no upper
bite issues yeah they've leaned in on
all angles familiar with yeah I measure
to buy some war bonds keep it subtle Wow
right in the middle of the cartoon hey I
think we can all agree that we need to
buy more war bugs so this is played in
movies before just a big ad firm I mean
at least now we just have a news network
devoted to it fly yeah so you can back
okay do that
sure so he's gonna put a bunch of papers
in there and learn how to fly a kite so
right so well he's still a go yeah I
don't know that's what I picture
Southwest pilots like okay so I'm not
gonna look out I feel like there's not a
lot of aeronautical knowledge I don't I
don't agree with that there's way too
close to them now you can do that way
too close
that way little pigma sure and he flies
what's yeah
well this is an air bottle fistfights
get tied up in bed sheets is he telling
this story next to like a gas line knots
I can't get over how that guy looks no
no no I think old harpoon you'll get oh
wow really
what planes sodomy this is a based on a
true story
yeah no I was just gonna ask so I
learned use a cannon well I wouldn't
start by throwing knives out of clouds
oh yeah hey guys by the way don't forget
to buy yourself some Warbucks Warbucks
guess what war bonds win the war because
yeah tornado war bonds what do you think
was gonna have us wait so what the war
bonds are are literally winning cuz all
the world yes
do not know history oh so they're like
piranhas war bonds
my god he blew oh I can't fun not only
help win the war
but they paid for our home our new
furniture our plane and as a matter of
fact if it wasn't for our war bond you
wouldn't be here that's right I shot a
loaded your mom because of war bonds for
your post-war Security register a navy
ward bond a lot bucks
Wow war bonds get you a house be safety
[Music]
furniture in your house Confederate lady
I don't even know if you need to
actually have sex I was told that if you
just erase us enough to round a war bond
a human child pops out hey remember that
part when he did the thing with his eyes
yeah I do
[Music]